hello and welcome to this video playing
plus from Norway okay I've been only
here yeah so here they usually try to
play without see for that definitely has
some pointers however how do you play it
exactly the check maybe check that might
make some sense not sure really but it's
a play will move for sure it prevents
Bishop g4 and in this position for
example if i would have developed to the
bishop just like that then Bishop g4 was
an option taking one of three and then
Bishop g5 this is not possible now okay
I wonder if Knight c3 is the right movie
in the first place I can also try to go
to see for you in this position
yeah that's interesting idea probably a
five first
as dead of night f1 g3 as well so I him
he does this and all night see force may
be of questionable value
okay let's try to get the night to g3
that's not a bad square or to e3 e3 is
also quite decent
it's probably shooting for a night f8
right of 896 something like that no well
here I thought Queenie two would be
quite embarrassing when you have to
return or find some great idea
yeah return and 32 is not a move that
I'm completely unhappy to make even
though not g6 FY the queen is not
ideally placed um okay yeah I guess
before him taking on c5 looks like a
threat okay he does not address it well
it's not a threat in this I mean it's
not that he had to do something urgently
but I felt like it's something I'm happy
to play okay I wonder this also Bishop
g4 maybe in some cases the queen is not
great now only two as night f1 is some
is coming
then it's got not G form ok I think I'll
move out of this and prepare 92 to see
form night wants to go to sea for any
way here now that looks ok i think his
counter play on the King side is not
looking so dangerous at the moment
because it is completely without any
pawns so something like Knight to f4
Bishop to g4 does not feel very
threatening
neither for was the problem this way I
moved the Queen I 192 to see 492
immediately there was not therefore he
is here it's not clear what his movers
actually
it's taking a very long time set I said
no he is connected yeah this is an
interesting move of course I was
thinking to take it but ultimately I
thought that just getting the night over
to see for must be right the bishop or
d3 does not seem very important here I
know if she's shooting from night eh SIA
for something like that I don't know h5
ok all the way up to h4 ok so I'm
dropping this back
briefly thinking now Knight takes e4 sis
school it's nonsense this is far too
crazy this move um Bishop a 60 ever is
not nonsense at all okay I have to be
ready for this put the night to be 54
Griffin
okay so what is he going for Bishop to
g5 here maybe on trying to trade this
yeah I wonder have f4 as a movie I want
it I could be rather weakening okay
let's do this
yeah I wonder if c4 is a useful move the
night coming to see for would be cool
but I don't see how actually exactly why
as c1 be 3d to what that's a very long
very long journey for the night
yeah maybe still I mean I have to be a
bit alert about c4 or something like
this that's surprising f5 looks like
it's by far week too much weaken other
that's beginning too much time morning
it's not hanging get on d6 my queen is
also unprotected so that's pretty
substantial pressure that that looks a
little bit to eat there let's see Bishop
to g5 yes I guess and then just take the
aid um let's look for one moment down
that is all protected I don't have to
give away the b5 phone ok seeing where
it is going
I'm not threatening anything yeah but so
i can check grab everything black for
offense on time that doesn't it didn't
look good I mean I think at times I
don't think that this is a substantial
problem for him maybe I should be
somewhat bad of it it feels a little bit
too slow what I'm doing here Navy and
okay went down and now I went for the
regrouping 36 mm that's a bit slow it
was always possible to take a for may be
here this is actually good because this
is now hard to protect and you don't
want g5 him yeah the ticking wasn't bad
but i think what edit is also not not
bad at all it keeps full control that is
a good structure and black has very
little active that you can do and bring
the night around and it didn't really do
much against it losing lots of time yeah
i was mostly waiting for him to play
that to open it up at here should go if
all this is still not that clear
position being relatively closed after
that after this i think i should win
yeah that's plus 3 yeah so because of
all the weak bones next position is just
just falling falling apart yeah it's a
it's difficult to handle that kind of
benoni structure with black having dead
space it's very delicate delicate
balance of play okay i hope you enjoyed
the game thanks for watching